tom pelicero who's my colleague from the
nfl media group who joins us now from
the owner's meetings in the metroplex in
state of texas how are you tom
i'm fantastic rich how are you i'm doing
well all right
i'll give you the floor your uh your
response to all that is what
well first of all i would say i'm not
doubling down on anything i would just
simply say that right now
we are picking at semantics regarding
certain things that i reported in a
story that was not a story about an
argument with marvin jones that was one
sentence in a much broader story about
the environment
in jacksonville if you go back and you
listen to urban meyer's uh press
conference on sunday after the game he
actually confirms a great deal
of what i had reported uh he
acknowledged that marvin jones was upset
about uh repeated criticism of the wide
receiver group he said that they had a
conversation
i refer to it as an argument which is
how it was described to me
uh again that's a semantic difference
you can ask my wife about that
i disagreed on that before um
you know the other detail that i had not
seen urban asked about was marvin jones
not being in the facility at one point
because he was so upset um that is
absolutely
accurate
uh you know there's of course the
benching of james robinson and the
details there where urban has um you
know said it was injury related then
said it was he's not involved and it's
the assistant coaches when in fact he
was the one who ordered the benching and
kept uh james robinson out of the game
it was only when trevor lawrence
intervened the robinson went back in and
then there's the uh
staff meeting which
urban denies uh calling
his assistant coaches losers
uh again we're into a semantic territory
here because he also again
noted immediately after that that he yes
it's very hard on coaches and very
demanding
the message
in the meeting regardless of what he
called
and how he used certain words the
message of the meeting was he's a winner
the assistant coaches are losers and he
emphasized this in the meeting by going
around the room pointing at each coach
and saying have you won and he did not
mean that rhetorically he wanted an
answer and guys had to
uncomfortably defend themselves and
their resumes and rich i can't tell you
how many people within the league from
every you know every different position
from head coaches to assistant coaches
front office people other media members
have called me since then and and i ask
all the you know the coaches in
particular is this normal and everyone
says no they've never heard of anything
like that but it's not about one
argument or conversation it's not about
one
staff meeting it is about the way that
that fits into the pattern
in a pervasively
negative environment that quite frankly
is unlike anything that i've heard in my
close to 20 years covering the nfl and
that's something i mentioned on this
show yesterday is how everybody talks
i've never been around
a group of people quite like football
people who talk everybody talks
everybody cheddar chatters and jibber
jabbers or
or jive turkeys or what have you to use
the harbaugh phrase right or gobble
gobbles quite like nfl people and the
thing that jumped out at me as well
on off your off of your piece from over
the weekend that was just remarkable i
had to read it twice to be honest with
you tom uh was that jaguar players
unburdened themselves to rams players in
los angeles after losing to them and
that's the way players talk i totally
believe that that that is something that
happens all the time so that's what you
heard that jaguar players unburden
themselves to rams players like you have
no idea what's going on around here
pretty much well in fact too yes i was
told that and that was in the story that
you know jaguars players were basically
telling rams players the same thing that
i've heard you know throughout the
course the offseason which is urban
meyer does not treat them like you know
adults in many cases guys who have kids
have families uh he's still
kind of approaching them like their 19
year old college kids and in fact you
know i also got many calls uh over the
weekend from agents of jaguars players
who all said
number one
everything in that story is accurate as
far as players know and number two it's
just scratching the surface and in fact
i had uh one prominent agent tell me
that the same thing happened after the
tennessee game which was a jaguars
player came up to one of his players on
the titans and was saying get me out of
here now you know that happens with
losing okay let's let's you know kind of
level set here any time you're 2 and 11
there's going to be some you know
casting blame and there's going to be
some griping and complaining and
everybody just you know wants the season
to be over one of the things that is
unique
in jacksonville is urban meyer when he
speaks publicly
often
is casting blame on whether it's the
players or his assistant coaches
um and that's not going over well that's
one of the things that
was upsetting for marvin jones has been
upsetting for other players is they feel
like they're getting blamed and aired
out publicly when there's you know quite
clearly some institutional things that
are not uh not in line with what people
expect an nfl program to be tom pelicero
here on the rich eisen show and the
other i guess outlier or difference
because you're right i mean when teams
are 2 and 11 players are always saying
get me out of here this is terrible
u-haul
you know dion taught me that phrase
years and years and years ago that the
u-haul's backed up that players are done
they're essentially want to get out and
they're ready to back the u-haul up and
go home and the jaguars are playing
u-haul games right now and the pro the
difference is also is a coach with
uh an absolute sterling
uh
winning record right coming in and i say
that just in terms of wins and losses we
know that there's always been
uh baggage of note regarding urban meyer
uh at his college stops but i mean
there's no question this guy
is a winner the guy puts w's on the
board and hangs banners and beats alma
maters like mine you know repeatedly
so he's not used to it we're not used to
talking about him this way and then of
course there's this sense of the jaguars
saying
how is he not that guy still
so what's the next steps here in that
regard tom what's happening there right
now
well jaguar's owner shot khan uh
addressed the coaching staff yesterday
uh told them to tighten up no more leaks
um the fact that i'm telling you that
happened would indicate that those
efforts may not be entirely successful
wow okay he also spoke to uh reporters i
believe on his yacht last night uh
celebrating his 10-year anniversary as
the
jaguars owner uh and if you read the
quotes some of which are are on nfl.com
right now
it's certainly not a strong endorsement
it's very much they're going to evaluate
things they're not used to having drama
uh surrounding the jaguars in fact shad
made a and shot is somebody who i you
know have a great deal of respect for
one of the great you know success
stories and how he came up making his
fortune in the the car bumper business
you know truly self-made and so
impressive in in many ways um you know
but he was he was joking about the fact
that normally it's just well the lowly
jaguars they're bad and everybody leaves
us alone whereas in this case people
there's a heightened focus and there is
drama which is something that they're
not accustomed to one quote also that
jumped out of me was he said this roster
is much better than winning two games
which is a pretty clear indication that
he believes
they should not be two and 11 right now
and if the roster is not the problem
that infers that coaching
must be at least a part of the issue
that they have right now so yeah i would
entirely expect that there's going to be
a thorough evaluation of everything
going on
you know again based on shad's
background and his history in the nfl he
is he is inclined to give people time
gus bradley got into a fourth season um
despite all the losing that they did
with a young rebuilding team doug marone
was around for four full seasons um
obviously had the one run to the afc
championship game and then but you know
the overall record was not great but
they would you know exercise patience
there
the question that the chad khan and the
people advising him have to answer is
can it get better with urban meyer as
the head coach because one of the
challenges that they're going to have is
they've already had significant staff
turnover going back to the off season
when uh his hand-picked strength
conditioning coach resigned after some
racial comments from his days at iowa
resurfaced his special teams coordinator
had to take a leave of absence did not
return his chief of staff just left for
the university of texas there's a report
that his tight ends coach is taking
another job i am personally aware of
multiple assistants who are actively
looking for other jobs because under no
circumstances do they want to return are
you going to be able to get good coaches
to come down there are there people who
trust urban meyer enough to
go in and fill those roles you know and
there's also agents who say you know
it's going to be hard they're not going
to be able to get free agents uh money
and no state income tax generally can
fix at least some of that right but in
terms of program building just with the
environment that that's created there um
they're they're going to have some
challenges and they've got to figure out
and shots got to make a determination
can urban meyer be the guy to fix it
well and then there's the question about
uh trevor lawrence right
and if tom uh we're having tom pelicero
nfl network here on the rich eisen show
if we're having a conversation about
which
you know insanely successful
uh person from the collegiate level can
have that translating to the pros and
who's more likely to have that right now
you'd have to say it's still trevor
lawrence over the coach and the question
is is
what is trevor lawrence thinking
and what is the general sense of his
development and what is he getting out
of the relationship with a coach again
who
brought an
immense
resume with him from the collegiate
level
what's that conversation like right now
do you think internally or
at all tom
that is a fantastic question and another
important one that shad khan is going to
need to answer
uh in the weeks to come what we know
is that again trevor lawrence had to get
involved in a situation where one of
their best players was on the sideline
and had to
in essence put him back into the game
himself uh also said publicly you know
something along the lines i'm
paraphrasing here but i'm the one on the
field i'm the one who sees where all the
pieces are he's one of our best players
he needs to be in the game that's not a
common thing that you hear from a rookie
quarterback and i don't think that
trevor lawrence meant anything negative
by it but he's clearly feeling like he
needs to take
further ownership over what's going on
uh offensively they had a terrible game
against tennessee they got shut out over
the past seven games they scored 64
points which is the fewest
in
seven games in jaguars history and that
is not exactly a franchise history
filled with juggernaut offenses so
they're bad right now and you have to
you know look into that is it you know
as simple as urban meyer you know fires
the whole offensive coaching staff
i mean that is one potential option i'm
sure but then who are you going to get
who is going to want to come in uh to a
place where you'll go all the way back
to the preseason and after the second
pre-season game
bourbon meyer in a staff meeting
threatened everyone's jobs
said he's sick of being embarrassed
after two pre-season losses he's sick of
being embarrassed and if they don't
start winning immediately a lot of these
guys will not be back next year that was
that was the first moment that as much
as there had been signs of it through
the off season
really shook some people at the time in
terms of
is is he going to understand how this
works in the nfl and at the time people
made the point to me that hey he was
brought in because he's you know hard
charging he's going to turn around the
program yeah he's hard on people but we
need that it's been a losing
organization for so long it just seems
to have taken on a different context as
the season
has gone along here and
again when you're talking about changes
or what can fix it okay it's one thing
to say we're going to get rid of these
people can you bring in good people to
replace them knowing that you know if
nothing else it's very apparent that if
urban meyer gets a second season he is
in no way guaranteed a third so when
does shaad khan show up at the owners
meeting is that today when he'll be
there and i'm sure
all the cameras likely
yeah likely tomorrow um today is the
labor seminar which is where they do the
salary cap projection and you know so
it's a lot of the salary cap people here
i have not seen i don't believe a single
owner uh it starts late morning tomorrow
so a lot of guys will take their private
jets in in the morning and uh be here so
it'll be an interesting yeah it'll be an
interesting day uh to say the least yeah
of course tom because i mean if if he's
if john's saying we're not used to this
sort of scrutiny and
you know and conversation being had
surrounding our football team
uh i proffer to say that even with this
being i guess a home game for jerry
jones
uh the owner that's going to have the
most camera trained on him is going to
be is going to be sean khan there's no
question about that come on jerry will
find the cameras that's true too i'm not
i'm not too concerned for him and so
then
is vegas getting a super bowl out of
this uh out of this meeting is that the
the major headline to be coming out of
what this meeting would be for the
ownership yes and that's been uh assumed
for some time i believe it's after the
2023 season um and they'll take a vote
my understanding is it's a ceremonial
vote uh las vegas like like everywhere
that builds a new stadium you generally
uh get a super bowl within the next five
years there's been some
um
movement because of different issues
going on including when the league
extended the regular season one super
bowl that was supposed to be in new
orleans got pushed back into mardi gras
which was kind of a non-starter for the
nfl right which is what opened up this
this particular super bowl uh for the
raiders so yes that's the the full
expectation is it'll be a
a las vegas super bowl which should be
quite the spectacle in a couple of years
and then the last thing that i saw you
were reporting on with uh our our
colleague and friend mike garfollo um
that that the league is mandating tier
one and tier two employees to get a
booster shot by two days after christmas
otherwise they'll no longer be
considered fully vaccinated by the nfl
what does that mean
what does that mean
tier one and tier two staff is covering
um you know tier one staff includes
coaches it includes anybody who's
working directly with players tier two
it's the access is slightly different
but again it's people who can be around
players so in essence players are not
required to get a booster shot at this
time that's something they would have to
be uh talking with the union with in
terms of updating the coveted protocols
and that may happen uh you know at some
point but players are not you know
required to get vaccinated period as of
now so i don't anticipate there's going
to be any kind of a mandate
not during the 2021 season uh certainly
but you know the vast majority of
coaches are uh
vaccinated at this point uh so don't
anticipate a ton of uh ripple effects i
think it's like 99 point something
percent of all staff
is vaccinated but it's a reflection of
what happened within the league uh
yesterday i mean the fact that you had
36 players
go on the uh covet lists which is double
the largest number in two years of these
protocols that have ever gone on in a
single day in the season uh it's a
reflection of where you're at right now
in terms of
the united states you know the nfl based
upon their data and they do genomic
sequencing and whatnot to figure out you
know exactly how virus came in what
strains there are is it being passed
from the facility is it not and like
five out of every
uh that they've seen over the season
have been
from community spread so you know the
other thing to anticipate and not to
take a completely dark turn here rich
but generally speaking when you see
spikes
in um the positivity rate for
professional sports leagues that usually
means that the rest of the country is a
couple weeks behind from a similar spike
the reason being because professional
sports leagues are one of the only
places where you regularly test
asymptomatic individuals so if they're
catching these cases even among fully
vaccinated uh individuals what that
tells you is there's probably a lot of
people walking around this country right
now who have coveted may be spreading it
and don't know it because they're not
getting regularly tested and so this is
all going to be you know i know there's
going to be a presentation here at the
league meetings about what that means
it's been full steam ahead they have not
rescheduled a single game
through the course of this season there
are protocols and procedures in place if
that happens
but you know at this point the nfl fully
intends to play this season on time and
have super bowl on time in los angeles
in february tom appreciate the time um
and uh your or your excellent reporting
and uh your two cents let's do this
again sometime soon you'll be safe any
time that's tom pelicero i follow him on
twitter you should as well at tom
pelisaro here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here